there's people people coming to youtube
thinking they can succeed right away and
what they don't
like youtube is not about making one
banger videos if
like the way i see youtube is that if
you make enough videos
eventually eventually you're gonna get
one that's on the algorithm
and i've seen so many channels that i
just have like uh
have like a thousand views in every
video and then one view one video gets
like 200 300 sometimes a million views
and they just can't recreate that yeah
and it's about
being able to consistently grow your
views it's not about getting that one
bang
of video yeah it's about slowly like
some people rise up very quickly but you
shouldn't
you shouldn't ever think that you're
gonna be one of those people those are
like the lucky ones
but i believe that if you play your
cards right and if you
know what you're doing in terms of
marketing on youtube there is a path
that you can take that is
that is sustainable growth yeah youtube
to me
isn't about getting 15 minutes of fame
and then you've made it it's about
getting 15 minutes of fame
every day yeah consistently you know
yeah it's about making 10 videos that
are good
and are growing yeah consistently and
never stopping and that's why burnout
exists
it's because once you finish one video
you have like a day of rest and you
realize you got to do it
all over again no matter how good the
last one yeah yeah it doesn't matter
because that's not going to be like
yeah you're not you're not a movie
that's not going to pay your bills yeah
yeah
yeah okay do you guys remember an exact
point when you just kind of realized
like you know when you started youtube
you're like i can do this forever
making videos talking about anime
[ __ ] easy this is like the dream job
i can do this forever
do you do you ever have did you ever
have a point when you're just like
man what's the end game on this like
what am i doing
yeah but like you know when i when i
worked at mcdonald's i didn't think like
yo what's the end game with this
i mean how many mug flurries do i got to
make but like like did you ever think
man how much longer can i keep just
making mcflurries
what is there what is there off the shop
manager what's above that
i did the moment i started working at
mcdonald's i was like i want to leave
here so [ __ ] bad
but i really want that new xbox but i
really want to [ __ ] that
yeah that's the end game right that's
the goal that is
i guess it's hard because i think
what i want out of youtube changes
constantly yeah i think
right now uh i'm in a place where i
think
i'm the best where i've ever been on
youtube i think i've got my mental
health
the best place where it's ever been on
youtube i really do separate it and i
really do take care of myself which is
weird because i got a comment on my a
few recent videos that like is connor
doing okay
it's kind of it's kind of it's there's
always those comments and like
it's kind of depressed yeah yeah and
it's weird cause it's like dude like if
i'm
if i am more it's probably something
more real than the videos if anything
yeah i've stopped caring about if i look
kind of
annoyed or depressed at any point yeah
yeah like maybe when i'm directing
someone
or doing something like that but you
don't have to bother with like the
business smile right now no no i just
kind of like now i just turn on the
camera and i just literally just do
me which and i feel like it's been and
it's being received better than ever
yeah right and it's hard to do that but
also i think because i've gotten such a
good control over the separation of job
and like like you know what i'm doing
like when i went away this weekend [ __ ]
to
i did not think about youtube for one
moment for like four days
yeah i had to upload a video at one
point but that's literally just one
point in the evening where i schedule it
and i just that's it like i just don't
think about youtube when i'm not working
now
yeah and i don't know how i managed to
do that because i remember there was a
time when i
like i said in london i could not turn
it off like i could not stop thinking
about youtube
everything was youtube like what am i
going to do next what's the new idea
what's this cause i remember you
messaged me a couple of days ago when
you were still up in new york we had
like a really brief
discussion about it about how connor was
like
is it bad that i'm starting to care less
about youtube
not in the sense of like i don't care
about videos yeah but it doesn't
take over my life as much yeah i i i
will get back to your question uh later
but
i guess cause it's weird because my
whole youtube career if you will
i've always thought about it yeah always
like i don't stop thinking about it and
i'm like is it bad that i have
a lot large large periods of time like
two three days where i can just not
think about it
is that bad like i don't know am i a bad
youtuber no no that's like yours
that's healthy because that's that's
what i'm trying to do right i haven't
been able to achieve that
at all right i think throughout my
youtube career really i think that's my
problem i think like i wish i could tell
you how i did it
like this this year this year especially
i think i've been like close to burnout
around like
[ __ ] ten years i feel like you've
i can feel that you're stressed about it
yeah and i think i think that's just
because normally i'm used to
a change in environment or a change in
breakthrough just just because of like
the global situation
we've not been able to lock down
definitely lockdown has just made it
like ten times worse
and i know like i've gone and gotten a
few comments recently like
oh god uploading videos left what's
going on there and it's like there's
nothing going on i just
i'm just staring at the blog
the thing that really stresses me out is
this notion that
if you don't upload like in the viewer's
mind if you don't upload
you're dead like everyone's thinking
either he's dead or
man he must be working on a banger video
right here he must be recording all his
time into this [ __ ] bag of video and
it's just
sometimes that just makes it more
pressure like especially if there's a
long break that man
coming back with just another of the
same upload i've been doing before just
makes it really difficult
that's that's one thing that i guess is
like the good thing about having a
schedule or like good thing about having
a time frame of like okay
it's been however many days i have to
upload a video right because
that expectation gets completely thrown
out the window yeah and then when you do
release that banger of a video it's a
it's a pleasant surprise right you're
like oh [ __ ]
my man was able to do this in the same
time frame as a regular video all right
i see you
because it it's and i know it's an
unhealthy mindset but sometimes even
when i'm on holiday
or even when like i'm like away i'm like
i'm i'm secretly thinking to myself like
this could have been time that i've used
it i was doing something
with my channel
yeah i really don't i i guess okay
having a like a little bit of backlog of
videos is like
this that's it because i i have never
in my youtube career felt like i've been
on top of my work
because unlike you guys i finish a video
i upload it and that's
that grace period like that that 20 to
48 hour grace period after i
upload a video that's my holiday because
that's the only time i can mentally be
like okay
i deserve this break i feel
uncomfortable if i'm not
at least four or five videos recorded
ahead yeah like they might not be edited
and done but like i don't feel
comfortable unless i have that buffer
because
like for example uh when i moved back to
my parents
uh before moving to japan like i just
wasn't in the mood because i hated the
environment i
love my parents but i just didn't like
being home yeah and i just wasn't i just
didn't want to make videos
so i just didn't and then also when i
moved to japan i wanted to
enjoy japan for the first month so i
didn't make videos for a month
i didn't feel bad about that yeah
because i had the i had the backlog and
i
completely used all of my backlog yeah
that month
and also i just don't have to worry
about taking
a weekend off or taking four like i
haven't made a video or done any video
stuff in about a week and a half now
i don't know why i'm pretty just i just
can't think of ideas right now i've also
been really [ __ ] busy i mean we
uh did a with a video that we can't talk
about yet yeah that's coming out soon
we did a special thing yeah we did a
special video and then also we had the
podcast in between there and then i've
been really busy and i was way behind on
a bunch of other stuff so
it's just like having that backlog even
if okay this is my advice to you khan
even if you
like have to do a month between each
upload try and get like one or two
videos backlog that you can like drip
out so that you can at least then take
that those one or two days off and be
like
i'm not gonna think about it because i
don't need to yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
take these days off and i know i'm
taking these days
off so why would i ruin them by thinking
about like oh [ __ ] what are the fiverr
sellers up to
what are they doing yeah what porn are
they drawing you know what i mean like i
don't know i i really
it's it's difficult i guess i've [ __ ]
it up so many times that i've learned
now